you reject the Trinity yes you uh what's
what's your belief system you Muslim I I
would just say I'm a Unitarian I believe
that go is Yahweh and Jesus is not
Yahweh do you believe the Bible I
believe the parts that are true what
does that even mean what's your timate
principle for when it's true and when
it's not uh when it corresponds to
reality so that's just what the system
that you assume well like for instance
like we know that trinitarians added
first John 57 so we can't say every
single verse is true well the Trinity is
not based on the Trinity is not based on
that verse anyway what's your epistemic
principle you said the Trinity the
trinitarians did this I'm asking your
abic principle you said it's reality
what does that mean so when the Bible
corresponds to reality is when it's true
so like if if if it presents some sort
of Truth is when it's true so that's a
circle well truth is what corresponds to
reality so reality is when it
corresponds to what you just said is
what the Bible says when it's your
position so how do you what's your
epistemic principle is what I'm asking
the epistemic principle is we what the
Bible says and we anal don't accept the
Bible you said when it's according to
what's true you have a prior principle
what's the basis of the prior principle
the the prior principle is logic
according to reality so we read the
Bible and we we ask it means we read the
Bible and we ask what do the words mean
and do they do they violate the laws of
logic you're going okay so not what's
the basis for believing in the laws of
logic the basis of believing the laws of
logic is that we use our mind to form
abstract
how does use justify that doesn't mean
that it that doesn't explain its
existence how it is where it is right so
reality exists right reality ex what is
that so you're making all these
metaphysical assertions I don't know
what those things I mean there a lot of
those ories are just restatements so one
of your problems Jay is now the
personal so are you gonna answer an
epistemic question or just keep going in
circles well okay I want make it
personal but I'll say this is this is
the problem with prup Pres it actually
has nothing to do with presup it's an
epistemic question so yep yeah so prup
actually gets epistemology wrong oh
really are you a foundational uh I would
say I believe in correspondence theory
of truth that has nothing to do with
foundationalism okay well could you
please define foundationalism do you
think there's self-evident maxims
because it seems like you keep just
referring to these sort of self-evident
things like logic and I'm ask for
justification yeah so we have to we have
to we have to assume certain things yes
well how do we know what the right
assumptions are you said logic what's we
can we can so absolute certainty when
you say no I would Define that as
absolute certainty of Truth so we don't
even have to have we don't have to have
absolute surrender okay well I would say
when you when you use the word term no
we can't really know anything okay how
do you know that's a contradiction right
there yes so we we can we can we can for
how do you know how do you know that you
can't know anything you just said that
you know that we can't know anything
that's a contradiction it's a univ do do
you know that do you know that you I
would say we can form beliefs that we
think are true but they may not be true
yeah but you're missing the point
because every time you assert something
that's a knowledge claim and you're also
saying that we can't know knowledge
claims you give up yet we can't we on
you don't know epistemology and you're
not familiar with like the basics of
circular claims we we can believe
something but we can't know it's true at
any there we go so that's fism I believe
I believe it know it might be false
you're making a universal claim that is
the same time not Universal that's a
contradiction I can well let me say this
I I can I can believe a proposition but
I can't know it's true but you're
missing the point because that
proposition itself ised to be a
universal claim and you're you're
canceling it out by the next statement
okay so let's let's go with this can we
can we agree that can we agree that
there's a reality that exists uh again
I'm not going to grant you your dogmatic
assertion any more than you would grant
me in a debate my dogmatic assertion
okay well in my are you g to grant me in
a debate if I just say the Trinity just
is no I'm not okay so I'm not going to
Grant you well my view of logic just is
and so just give me that I get to start
there no you don't okay yeah we're
trying we're trying to build our
epistemological foundations for me it
starts with reality which is an
emanation of that's an meaningless
metaphysical assertion that you've not
justified if you get to just start with
that and you get to pack all this
metaphysical baggage into it I get to do
the same where should I start where
should I start what is more fun you need
to give me a coherent starting point I'm
saying that I can't think of anything
more fundamental than reality itself the
fact that you can't think of it doesn't
make it justified in understand that I'm
just saying I and there may be something
more fundamental reality position isn't
justifiable that's fine it's justifiable
as far as I can tell let me say that so
if you can if you can so that's asking
philology that means it gets you nowhere
if you can give me something more
fundamental than reality I'll go with it
but as of this moment I can't think of
anything first of all the irony of that
is that in history of philosophy words
like reality or reasoning are vastly
elastic phrases that various
philosophers stick all kinds of things
into so the idea that something like
reality is self-evident which is I think
where you're trying to go is a dead end
because it's not even answering the
question of how do we know that that's
self-evidence this is called the
Criterion problem so in other words if
you assert something as self-evident as
the starting point of a criteria of a
worldview whatever we need to know why
that's the thing that's self-evident and
why the other things aren't and the
problem right there is you've got
another standard by which you're
dividing the the self-evident and the
non- self-evident things out and so if
there's a prior standard then the
self-evident things aren't self-evident
because they're relying on another
standard so you're you're in an infinite
regress of self-referencing circular
starting points okay well what I would
say is what the Preppers do is they
presuppose the truth of the Bible and
and judge reality according and judge
the rest of their observations according
to that what I do is I I judge the Bible
according to what my rational mind and
empirical observations tell me is true
but which for which you have no basis
okay yeah but if the if the Bible
says Okay but well here's here's here's
the situation who has a better
methodology if the Bible says if the
Bible says the moon is made of cheese
would we presuppose a true or we go to
the moon and find out if it's made of
cheese or not but the Bible doesn't say
that so that's a analogy well let's say
let's say the work because that's that
would be like me telling you what if
reality says the moon is made of cheese
you wouldn't accept that reality let's
do this a let's do this so this this was
enough do you believe that the Bible
teaches the Trinity bro uh I can I can
see how if you piece certain verses
together you would get a very skeletal
framework for the Trinity but it
wouldn't be the full Trinity doctrine
that has been developed through the
councils and everything how is it that
how is it that there's dozens and dozens
of references throughout the Old
Testament I did a 5H hour lecture series
just on the Old Testament references to
multiplicity in Yahweh problem with the
idea that the Trinity is in the Old
Testament is that there are literally
zero Jews who were trinitarian so not
true I've got about I've got five Jewish
texts right here arguing that the Old
Testament had a multiplicity of persons
in Yahweh you can you can say there's so
so I've got them right here I've got
them literally on the screen yeah I see
the screen I see the screen what I'm
saying is I assume one of them is
probably is it seagull's two powers in
heaven correct the other one is
summers's bodies of God the other one is
Schaefer there's also boarin yeah so the
problem with the problem with two powers
in heaven theory is you need three to
make a trinity but but the argument is
not that the early Jewish people were
strictly Orthodox trinitarians the
argument is that they're not Unitarian
that's the point so if you went to um by
the way the thousands of the thousands
of Jews that begin the church are
trinitarian in the book of Acts in in my
opinion now the book of Acts is is
anti-trinitarian as it gets so you're
just asserting that I'm talking about
the Jewish Christians as the basis of
the church confess the deity of the
person of Christ for example when
Stephen is stoned he's stoned because he
he confesses the deity of Christ okay
you're gonna have to prove that to me I
I just have a I have a question for you
this is 1 Corinthians 10 verse here and
it says here that we must not put Christ
to the test as some of them did and were
destroyed by serpents when did uh the
Israelites put Christ to the test and
then as a result were killed by serpents
uh I remember when they put Christ to
the test and were killed by serpents you
know what this is that be a reference to
something that happened in the New
Testament or the Old Testament it's the
book of numbers so you're not familiar
with the Bible no no I am I okay that's
you would know that that's the Book of
Numbers well here's the problem I knew I
knew numbers you know problem the
problem is not just it's like John 3:14
just as Moses lifted the rod and you
know healed the people from the servant
yeah so so right here so when did when
did they put Christ to the test and then
as a result D the problem I had I did
not know that was a reference in numbers
the problem I have with that is that
Christ you don't know the Bible Well
Christ was not in the new in the Old
Testament so so again that's why I'm
asking you he says he is God logic text
writers Yep this is why I'm asking you
if you're saying that Christ was not in
the Old Testament what is Paul talking
about when he says that as some of the
Israelites put Christ to the test and as
a result were killed by serpents when
did this happened uh okay I guess that
would probably be a reference was it
Numbers 22 numbers 21 21 yeah so that is
an Old Testament huh okay okay John 5
when Jesus was talking to the Pharisees
and explains that no one sees the father
at any time yet Moses saw God face to
face Jesus is saying that he was there
on the mountain talking to Moses let me
ask a question did uh did blow past the
passages did did Jesus Christ in in any
of his discourses claim to be represent
before before yeah he just gave you he
literally just gave you a reference and
even you gave a reference when talk
about lifting up the serpent but you I
don't want you to get away from this
here so Paul is saying that Jesus was
the one who was tested by the Israelites
in numbers 21 right that appears to be
what he's saying okay so when we go to
numbers 21 and we see who actually was
tested it says that it was Yahweh who
they spoke against right and then Yahweh
sent him sent serpents upon them right
you see this verse five yeah and the
people spoke against God and against
Moses why have you brought us out to
Egypt to die in the wilderness there's
no food or water y Yad y then Yahweh
sent fiery serpents among the people and
they bit the people so that many people
of Israel died so the Yahweh that Paul
is saying was in the Old Testament is
actually Christ who was tested right
that could be a valid interpretation I
I'd have to look at it but from my from
my that from my understanding and when I
read the Epistles of Paul he seems he
seems to be anti-trinitarian as well
okay so how is he anti-trinitarian if he
says if he's identifying Christ as
Yahweh who was there in the Old
Testament being tested by the Israelites
it could be it could be a a a figurative
a represent a representative figurative
representative of what an agency type
thing where no agent is called Yahweh
the Bible literally says in Psalms 88318
that you alone are Yahweh Nehemiah 9:6
you alone whose name is Yahweh so Paul a
monotheistic Jew who's well familiar
with the law and the prophets is not
going to call a creature or an agent of
God Yahweh right yeah but you have to
understand sometimes the there are there
are verses in the Old Testament which
are are applied to Christ but that is oh
Yahweh verses y Yahweh versus there are
Yahweh verses that are applied to Christ
which those are the ones that he rejects
I don't reject them I don't reject those
no don't you said at the beginning that
the passages that do not conform with
Unitarianism and with quote reality are
the ones that you don't accept that was
the first thing you said when you came
on here no I never well oh did I okay
well I said I I didn't say that don't I
don't reject things because they don't
conform with Unitarianism the beginning
if I what I meant to say is I reject
them if they don't correspond to what's
true okay right so you're you have an
epistemic principle that is your own
position that judges the Bible it's what
this amounts to and you know the counter
evidence when the counter evidence comes
up they're all reinterpreted or rejected
yeah look look I want I want to thank
you for coming man take a look at this
like revisit this look at those Yahweh
passages and I would say let the Bible
speak for itself bro okay I do have a
lot of guests that I gotta get to but
all right thank you I do want to thank
you for coming all right okay oh bet
that was funny Jay you be cracking me up
dude you cracked me up because it's so
nonchalant